no one seems to recognize you in
bohemian rhapsody' what was it like and
is it weird that you're like I'm there
no I'd say that's the joy David being
able to play other people and do
characters that's that's me happiest I'm
just thrilled to be part of it I just
love this movie Romney's fantastic the
message of declaring yourself of who
you're gonna be it's just I have people
coming up to me just crying saying that
they love the movie so I'm thrilled I'm
thrilled to be part of it oh and I
understand that there's talks about
another Austin Powers movie true
there's talks about another Austin
Powers true there are right but I can
neither confirm nor deny the existence
or nonexistence of such a program should
they exist or not exist please give us a
little something that was like something
but it was like something nothing it's
likely to be from dr. Evil's point of
view really oh that's fantastic
and I can neither confirm nor deny such
existence what that sounds like it's a
somewhat of a confirmation
that's proprieties information last
thing you're presenting or you're
hosting tonight are you taking over are
you gonna take over no I'm just
presenting all right Dana Carvey we're
gonna have a little Wayne's World
reunion going on yes what are you gonna
do we're gonna do some stuff that's
gonna be on a teleprompter but it's fun
we had a great rehearsal yesterday he's
just a great comedian is fun
[Music]